we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I'm playing
this voicemail for two reasons number
one as I mentioned earlier in the show
all of our protests and George Floyd
coverage is being demonetised on YouTube
and Facebook so the fact that someone
called in and actually praised our
coverage really means a lot and number
two it has been really heartwarming to
see the number of people reaching out to
me and saying David I really appreciate
your coverage of the protest you're not
creating these false black/white hot
takes you're actually dealing with the
complex nature of what's going on here's
one voicemail caller who made a similar
point David wonders why I'm happy to be
a subscriber of yours is that you're
probably the best progressive
commentator out there you're not
delusional
you're not crazy and you honestly try to
report the news from an honest and
fact-based perspective and thanks for
covering the George Floyd story very
well and pointing out that this is a
story of many stories and not just one
thing that you need to focus on there's
so many problems in this country that
this is revealing thanks for being a
good reporter I I so appreciate that and
thanks to everybody who has been writing
in about about our coverage we've got a
great bonus show for you today don't
miss it get a membership at join
pakman.com to get instant access to the
bonus show I will see you then